[Music]
in a bizarre legal case a michigan
couple is being forced to adopt their
own biological children
after they were born through a surrogate
jordan and tammy meyer's twins were born
two weeks ago today but two judges
denied them the legal rights to the
infants
citing a decades-old anti-surrogacy law
nikki batis has been looking at the very
strange case nikki good morning to you
this is just bizarre
it's really bizarre tony good morning
tammy and jordan meyer were hoping for a
sibling for their two-year-old daughter
when tammy was diagnosed with breast
cancer several years ago
her medical treatment left her unable to
go through another pregnancy
so the couple found a gestational
surrogate to carry
their biological child but now to get
the legal rights to their two-week-old
twins
they have to adopt them and initially i
you know i i thought i'm too young and
there's no way it couldn't be breast
cancer
nearly six years ago tammy myers learned
she was in a battle
for her life my first two questions for
her were
how long do i have and my second
question was
can i have more children can i still
have another baby now tammy and her
husband jordan
are facing a new fight this time for the
rights to their newborn twins
tammy froze her eggs after her breast
cancer diagnosis
she is doing better and in 2019 she and
her husband decided to grow their family
they turned to gestational surrogacy did
you ever
think you would be in the situation you
are having to adopt your own two
children
we really truly didn't believe that
someone could could hear the history
and not give us rights tammy and jordan
found their surrogate lauren vermilia
after posting on facebook
lauren who is married with two children
of her own
live nearby and volunteered to carry the
myers child for free
i lasted my dad's pancreatic cancer 11
years ago and just i know what
cancer can take away from you and just
to be able to
help bring that hope back to somebody
just
really really appealed to me and my
husband soon after
two of the myers embryos were
transferred to lauren they learned they
were having
twins the process was going well until
the couple tried to get legal parental
rights
you were denied the pre-birth rights and
then also jordan you were denied
my rights as a father as well yeah two
judges in kent county michigan dismissed
the myers efforts to be named the legal
parents
they cited michigan's surrogate
parenting act of 1988
which states surrogacy contracts are
void and unenforceable
one judge wrote that there are genuine
concerns about the 1988 act
but those concerns are better left to
the legislative and political arena
i just stopped that's all i could do
i just i don't understand it it doesn't
make any sense ames and ellison myers
were born
january 11th a few weeks premature their
birth certificate names the surrogate
lauren
and her husband as the parents michigan
law states that i am a married woman
and so of course my husband would be the
father
of my children which they're not my
children either
melissa neckers is the myers attorney
she said since 2005
there have been at least 72 cases in
michigan
where judges have granted parents in
similar situations pre-birth legal
rights
to their biological children did they
understand the risk
they faced based not only on michigan's
law but also that they had a stranger as
a gestational carrier
they knew that there was risk but they
really believed that no
judge would actually hear their story
which had
so many additional layers of heartache
and
trauma that a judge wouldn't just want
to do the right thing
only two other states have similar
strict surrogacy laws
nebraska and louisiana michigan would be
the riskiest state to ever try and do a
surrogacy contract
michigan family law attorney barbara
holmier said the myers may have been
able to avoid this
if they went to another state it's also
very expensive to go out of state hire
lawyers and find surrogates and do
everything else right to to go out of
state do you think the law in michigan
needs to be updated
yeah i do since they legalize gay
marriage too this is a much bigger issue
there are a lot of couples
who want to have kids and they need to
use surrogates to do that
to adopt their children the myers will
now have to go through months of home
inspections
paperwork and even an fbi background
check
they're speaking out to help others we
just want the law to be updated our hope
is that
we will be the last family in michigan
in this situation where we are being
denied our own biological children
the myers currently cannot get the twins
on their health insurance
the babies are still in the newborn icu
but they are doing well
and will hopefully go home to their
parents and big sister corin soon
we reached out to a clerk for both
judges but we have not heard back
tony it's very strange one thing after
another we'll see if the political arena
picks it up nikki thank you very much